was not a good night for lamar jackson
with the pick six with the the sluggish
offensive performance before that their
first drive drive of the game was
incredible until the missed field goal
but look at that 14 for 24 162 passing
yards only 34 rushing yards and one
interception exited with a concussion
uh
and and you really wonder where this
ravens offense is willie sneed who who
seem to be talking as if he knows it's
over for him in baltimore yeah he was
very candid about lamar jackson having
to kind of look in the mirror and
identify his flaws and look for ways to
improve his game and and he has the
skills to do it yeah that's snead's
point right but they need to find a way
to improve and you know you've got
people out there saying that they need
to fire greg roman who not long ago was
considered to be a head coaching
candidate is that the key to unlocking
the offense i don't know but it's clear
that the passing game
needs to improve they lean on the
running game too much and on the nights
when the running game isn't going to be
there you got to be able to pass the
ball well yeah they they got to grow it
was a defensive game that that that
first i think we got to like make sure
that's known it really was it was a
struggle for both offenses it looked
like it was 50 mile per hour wind gusts
from what everybody was saying so it
didn't lend itself to a great throwing
night in general anyways you know so
and hey let's baltimore's offense
actually out gained buffalo by 120 yards
that's that's another thing that's a
little crazy another good drive that
ended up in a justin tucker miss field
goal but
you know as great as leslie frazier's
defensive game plan was and all that it
was amazing you're right mike
it's a part that's missing from
baltimore now
you know again i would have loved the
scene 17-3 lamar doesn't have the ball
snapped over his head and gets a chance
to maybe bring them back i wanted to see
that that was going to be interesting
but either way it's got to get better it
really does he's got to continue to get
better within that you know and greg
roman doesn't need to be fired they can
keep them that's fine but they got to
bring somebody else in to improve the
passing game there's got to be some new
fresh ideas and things that can help
make that part of their offense grow and
make lamar grow lamarr to me is yeah
you got to continue to push him
and and he's at a he's still at a young
part of his career he doesn't even know
what he doesn't know yet like as you
hear me say with a lot of young
quarterbacks so
uh i i do think there has to be some
thought process there to improving that
area with baltimore yeah this quote from
willie snead as blunt as it gets i think
if lamar knuckles down on that part of
his game the passing and really reaches
his full potential in that area the sky
is the limit it's just a matter of time
so it's on him i think this game is
going to be a wake-up call for him
hopefully this offseason we'll see what
he does next year so wake up call for
lamar jackson and i think for the ravens
organization they have a great
quarterback in lamar jackson now and
wouldn't they need to attract some
veteran competent receiver talent but
who wants to go there when they know
they're going to get the ball far fewer
times than they will anywhere else chris
no it's going to be a question that's
going to be an issue i don't know if
they'll be able to get those high-priced
difference-making type veteran players
that come there probably going to have
to do it through the draft and then
maybe get guys that are free agents who
are desperate to revive their career and
something like that and hopefully
baltimore can pick the right guy to go
okay yes he he can revive his career
he's talented it'll be have to be that
way but i can't imagine some you know
top free agent coming there to play
receiver no that's why they got dez
bryant this year now dez bryant was kind
of the internal compromise when guys
were clamoring for antonio brown but
still dez bryant fits into that category
hollywood brown's there because he was a
first round draft choice you think he's
going to sign a second contract with the
ravens do you think he's gonna re-up and
stay there or is he gonna say i want to
go to a place where they throw the ball
all over the place i want to go play
with justin herbert right i i think
that's very real possibility it's going
to be one of those if you're going to
continue to play this style of football
either they grow the passing game to
where wide receivers want to come there
or they got to think about every two or
three years drafting two or three to
replace those guys that leave in free
agency like you're explaining
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports